bonjour Anne faillit déjà développement
économique et Smart territoire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
ce projet on l'a initié en 2019 nous
avons candidaté auprès de la recette
pour la bande expérimentale 26 giga Hz
nous l'avons obtenu nous avons ensuite
grâce à l'aide de Nokia développé les
antennes qui permettent de faire
fonctionner cette 5G au Vélodrome et ses
antennes ont été installés l'année
dernière et ont été testés lors des
Championnats du monde de cyclisme
le spectateur va pouvoir prendre ses
propres images de l'événement et il va
pouvoir ce challenger par rapport à un
athlète il va pouvoir créer un avatar il
va pouvoir lui donner des
caractéristiques de la course et le
mettre en compétition par rapport à la
tête comme ça il devient beaucoup plus
acteur de la de l'événement sportif
cette 5G elle permet aux médias
à ceux qui prennent des vidéos au
photographe d'envoyer très très
rapidement leurs images à leur rédaction
et ils peuvent ainsi diffuser en temps
réel ce qu'il se passe sur la piste sans
délai de latence et puis enfin la 5G
c'est un peu plus technique mais elle
permet aussi de mieux gérer le bâtiment
elle permet par exemple d'avoir des
informations sur les réseaux les fluides
tout ce qui est lié au chauffage à l'eau
et elle nous permet d'identifier plus
facilement là où il y a des difficultés
donc d'y répondre plus facilement et
donc d'alléger notre facture en matière
de gestion de bâtiment